In our last video, we talked about
the importance and the difficulty
of protecting personally identifiable
information through anonymity in big data.
Now, anonymity means that individuals cannot be
identified. Another important element of privacy,
however, is confidentiality for what’s called
nonpublic information. In its simplest form,
confidentiality means that regardless of whether
individuals can be identified within the data,
their data will not be shared with people
they did not specifically allow to see it.
The first is that in conducting transactions,
companies do share limited amounts of information
with third parties. For example, if a person
goes to make a large purchase, it’s not uncommon
for the vendor to call the bank and ask whether
the person has enough money in the bank to make
that purchase. They’re just checking for what’s
called sufficient funds. And all the bank does is
tell them yes or no. And so, there’s a sharing
of a very small amount of information, but the
bank does not pass along the person’s account
numbers, their ID information, doesn’t give them
their actual balance; just says whether they
have enough to cover a particular transaction.
On the other hand, it is also sometimes the
case that information is stolen from companies.
Several companies have had their data stolen,
including credit card information, addresses,
and other important personal information. And
in some cases, companies have lost hundreds of
millions of dollars in business because consumers
were no longer confident that their information
would be safe.
Similarly, another limitation to confidentiality
is that companies sometimes had to give their
information to courts or government
regulators as part of law suits that
could’ve put them out of business completely
if they did not provide the information.
It’s a very awkward situation, but it does
come up occasionally. The trick with that
one is while it is a legal process, it is not
something that the users originally agreed to,
and so there is a violation of trust even if
what’s happening is technically a legal process.
However, these exceptions don’t call for a
complete lockdown on data because the data
does provide very important services, but it does
call for more care and attention. For example,
the National Science Foundation and the National
Institutes of Health have instituted policies that
researchers have to present a plan to provide
access to their data they use in their studies.
Additionally, there are insurance companies
that now provide insurance for the cost of data
breaches and companies should consider whether
they want to purchase that kind of insurance.
Finally, companies should very
carefully consider whether they
even need to have the confidential
information in the first place.
It’s clear that, things can go very wrong when
data is supposed to be confidential. But again,
this doesn’t call for a complete avoidance
of data with non-public information in it.
After all, that’s what makes things like
restaurant and movie recommendations work so well,
and it’s certainly important for using
big data to make medical discoveries.
Some of these benefits are of personal
conveniences and could theoretically be forgone,
but others have life and death consequences and
deserve to be maintained. For these reasons,
it’s important for companies to consider how
they’re going to deal with non-public information.
That way, the trust of regular people, who are
the consumers and people who benefit from big
data research, the trust can be maintained,
and big data can provide its full benefits.